[Music]
♪ Welcome to the neighborhood - ♪
♪ hey pup, paws up - ♪
♪ - if you want to do some good it’s “paw-si-ble!” ♪
♪ In your home, school, or park - ♪
♪ hey pup, paws up - ♪
♪ - every dog can make their bark it’s “paw-si-ble!” ♪
♪ When you don’t know what to do, ♪
♪ and you’re feeling stuck, ♪
♪ don’t wait for it to come to you just get your paws - ♪
♪ paws up! ♪
♪ That’s right, pup! ♪
♪ Now you know this jazzy song - ♪
♪ hey pup, paws up - ♪
♪ tap your paws and dance along, it’s “paw-si-ble!” ♪
♪ Come on, pup! Get those paws up! ♪
♪ Hey pup, paws up! ♪
♪ With the dox-ie family - ♪
♪ hey pup, paws up - ♪
♪ we can change Muttgomery, it’s “paw-si-ble!” ♪
♪ You got Greta, Pretzel, and their pups - ♪
♪ Poppy, Pippa, Pedro, Paxton, ♪
♪ and there’s Puck! ♪
♪ So come and join the neighborhood - ♪
♪ hey pup, paws up - ♪
♪ - you can help us do some good, it’s “paw-si –” ♪
♪ it’s “paw-si –” ♪
♪ it’s “paw-si-ble”! ♪